la stèle de l'avenue eiffel privé de dix
de ses onze colombes
une sculpture en bronze ciller puis
dérobé entre lundi et mardi au volant de
sa voiture c'est françois chaudron le
père d'une des victimes qui constate le
vol mardi après-midi sans en arrivant
donc au feu rouge là bon bien sûr on a
toujours un temps record pour cette
course est stand jeudi mais en manque un
morceau paul bon prix par la circulation
on épouse a pris en photo quand c'est
sidérant voilà ce matin c'est la
première fois que ce père de quatre
enfants s'approchent du monument
vandalisés il y a vingt ans dans
l'explosion il perdait sa fille de 19
ans est à de la compréhension et puis
surtout une forte émotion parce que
c'est un peu comme si on avait si je
perdais mon enfant encore une fois peut
dire oui ccc qu'un morceau de fait de
bronze une belle oeuvre et ça va au delà
ça va au-delà la stèle de l'avenue
eiffel avait été inauguré en 2003 une
oeuvre en bronze 280 kg composée de onze
colombes en hommage aux 11 victimes de
l'explosion de l'immeuble situé au 145
de la venue dans la nuit du 4 décembre
1999 le drame emporte marie joséphine et
man maman de colette et simone pour ses
deux soeurs le vol de la stèle est un
véritable traumatisme
on a compté renouent leurs enfants de
leurs parents
ça a été vraiment une horreur qu'ils ont
fait c'est de voir quand même le prénom
inscrit
ils ont dû voir ces petits colons
quelque chose je comprends pas une
enquête a été ouverte par la sûreté
publique de dijon qui dispose pour
l'instant de peu d'éléments
l'association des victimes a lancé un
appel à témoins et elle déposera plainte
dans les prochains jours